الرؤيه الاليه في عالم السيارات لا تساهم
في تحسين اديها فحسب بل بتغيير مفهومها
بالكل افضل طريقه لرصد مستقبال السيارات
مع الاله على ارض الواقع هي زياره معرض
لوس انجلوس السيارات
[موسيقى]
عوده لاحد اكبر معارض السيارات في العالم
هنا في المعرض السنوي للسيارات في لوس
انجلوس نرى تطبيق الرؤيه الاليه فسيارات
المستقبل تسمع وتبصر وتستنتج ثم تتخذ
قرارا والسيارات ذاتيه القياده خير مثال
منها مخصص للاجره ومنها ما هو للسباق
[موسيقى]
من التقنيات المستقبليه التي نشهدها في
هذا المعرض سياره تضم حاسوبا موصولا
بالانترنت يمكن استخدامه للعمل والترفيه
على حد سواء حتى انه يضم العاب الكترونيه
مع نظارات للواقع الافتراضي للبيع
[موسيقى]
اله تدخل ايضا في تسريع الانتاج والضمان
جوده كما في السيارات المطبوعه بطابعه
ثلاثيه الابعاد
[موسيقى]
في الاستديو ينضم الينا مصعب شعشع مؤسس
موقع عرب للسيارات اهلا بك مصعب
جديده طيب اليوم اتحدث عن سياره المستقبل
كيف تنظرون لسياره المستقبل في ظل الحديث
عن مجموعه متطوره من الطرازات من
التكنولوجيا شكرا جزيلا لك
سياره المستقبل
محطوط لها قالب معين له مواد التصنيع
الكمبيوتر وجوده الكمبيوترات الموجوده
فيها
والطاقه اللي بتمشي عليها سياره المستقبل
سواء كان الطاقه الكهربائيه او طاقه
هيدروجينيه ممكن تكون في المستقبل همم
تصاميم السيارات والثوره الصناعيه اللي عم
بتصير حاليا خلال ال 10 سنوات الماضيه
ادت بتغييرات جذريه بعمليه صناعه السيارات
واحد وبي مواصفات والفيتشرز اللي بامكان
صناع السيارات او الناس اللي بيحاولوا
يطوروا بقطاع السيارات يضيفوها على
السيارات عشان يسهلوا من حياه مقتني
السياره وسهلوا حياه ملاك السيارات بشكل
عام المستقبل هلا ميال اكثر للسيارات
الكهربائيه زي ما اغلب المشاهدين اكيد
بيعرفوا بنفس الوقت كمان ميال اكثر لموضوع
الاترم الاسترادنج والقياده الذاتيه همم
جزء كثير كبير من السيارات القادمه خلال
العشر سنين همم راح تكون اغلبها فيها
خصائص ومواصفات بتخلي السياره تقود ذاتها
بنفسها من خلال عدد كثير كثير مثل ما شفنا
بالتقرير عدد كثير كبير من الحساسات
وانظمه الليزر سيستم والسونار سيستم
اوروبا
ستكون خطه كامله لانتاج سيارات كهربائيه
في القاره طيب هل اليوم هذه التكنولوجيا
الذكيه الجديده احدثت تغيير في مفهوم مره
ثانيه شفنا في تقرير رافي نظرات افتراضيه
اجهزه كمبيوتر ذكيه والعاب الالكترونيه في
السياره يعني اكيد راح تصير السياره جزء
لا يتجزا من مقتنيات الانسان يعني كيف
الجوال سمارت فونس معنا صار جزء من حياتنا
اليوميه اللي عم بيصير انه السياره عم
تتحول لتصير كمان جزء لا يتجزا من حياه
الانسان موصوله معان موصوله بالكونكتيفيتي
مع الجوال والبيانات والاعدادات والامورات
وسيله اسهل وسيله اقرب للترفيه من هي فقط
للمواصلات يعني راح راح تبال هدوء ما في
داعي همم تزعج نفسك بالقياده كله بتشغل
انظمه معينه السياره بتقول حالها بحالها
من غير ما تدخل انت همم
تاخذ نفسها بنفسها هل نتوقع سيارات ذات
القياده ان تصبح حقيقه قريبا
المفروض انه تصير حقيقه ولكن ما اعتقد انا
خلال سنتين او ثلاث سنوات راح يتطلب
الموضوع اكثر الوقت نظرا انه في كمان
المشرعين للقوانين المروريه ونظرا لشركات
التامين انا موضوع السياره موضوع حساسنا
انه اي خطا او اي في ممكن ياثر للسلام
العامه والاطر المروريه وكل الامور هذه
فاعتقد ممكن يطول الموضوع اكثر من خمس
سنين ست سنين ممكن ابتوا عشر سنين
خذ نفسها انتم رجال تحب تقود السياره هي
راح تكون فيها ملل ولكن اللي عم بيصير انه
عم يجبر عليها جبرا يعني السيارات
الكهربائيه جزء كثير كبير من الناس ما
كانوا يفضلوها ولكن نظرا للقوانين
والتشريعات وارتفاع اسعار المحروقات بشكل
عام ادت ان الناس تاخذ قرار شراء سياره
كهربائيه
بنفسهم بروحهم راحوا يشتروا ودفعوا ثمنها
فاعتقد بالنسبه للقياده الذاتيه هتكون
مجبرا اخر بطل نفس الموضوع راح تكون لانه
السيارات كلها موصوله مع بعض ومرتبطه مع
بعض بشبكه واحده فمستحيل يخلو شخص شاذ عن
الشبكه هاي
لوحده سائق سياره محرك فيه وكل الاشخاص
سائقين سيارات القياده وكهربائيه فنوعا ما
راح تصير الزمن كيف الزمن الاحصنه قبل لما
بدا اختراع السيارات
ناس كان عندهم عربات خيول وفي ناس اخذوا
قرار انه يشتروا سيجاره فاحنا مقبلين على
هذه المرحله نفسها ممكن السيارات
التقليديه بنشوفها اليوم تكون هي عربات
الخيول للعشر سنين القادم والسيارات
الذكيه لسمارك كارز ممكن نسميهم يكون هو
لهم المستقبل وهم اللي تجبر كل الناس انه
يشتروهم خلال
خاصه وستكون ذكيه يعني اجهزه متطوره هل
هناك تحديات في صناعتها سمعنا من فتره في
ازمه رقائق الكترونيه مثلا الصناعتها
مشكله كثير كبيره بالمواد الاوليه للصناعه
السيارات لانه جزء كثير كبير من اجزاء
السيارات بطلت فقط حديد والمنيوم صار يدخل
فيهم عدد كثير كثير من المواد الاوليه او
حتى المواد التقنيه يعني الرقائق
الالكترونيه واحد همم من عناصر كثير كبيره
موجوده بالسياره حاليا بناء السياره
وبمواصفات السياره اللي قاعدين نتكلم عنها
السياره ذكيه وهذه العناصر عم بتكون فيها
محدوديه بالتصنيع فيها شورتج بالتصنيع عم
بتكون في مشاكل بنقص المواد الخام باجزاء
جدا مهمه بالسياره وعم بيصير في حصريه
ومونوبولي ببعض اجزاء من السياره بتصنع
بشركات شركه او شركتين فقط بالعالم اللي
بيصنعوها مثال مثلا الشاشات اللي داخل
السياره في فقط شركتين بالعالم بصنعوا
الشاشات تبعون السيارات فهاي بتكون فيها
كمان غير انه ندره وسعر مرتفع وقله انتاج
وانخفاض انتاج كمان ندخل بموضوع همم
الحصريه بالانتاج شكرا جزيلا عن وجهتك
معنا
للسيارات شكرا نورتنا